alors la dengue est une maladie
tropicale c'est ce qu'on appelle aussi
la grippe tropicale
c'est une maladie qui est transmise par
un virus et ce virus lui-même est
transporté par un moustique qui
s'appelle le moustique tigre de son en
latin aedes albopictus ce moustique
c'est aussi lui qui transmet le tycoon
gogniat est logique à ce moustique est
arrivé en france métropolitaine en 2004
environ il est arrivé dans le sud de la
france il a commencé à s'installer dans
le sud il s'est étendu un peu vers
l'ouest et puis il a commencé à remonter
remonter notamment le long de la vallée
du rhône et aujourd'hui il occupe à peu
près la moitié du territoire
alors c'est paradoxal c'est un moustique
qui lui même se déplace assez peu tout
seul mais par contre c'est un moustique
qui s'est glissée dans les voitures dans
les trains dans les avions
et c'est comme ça qu'il a petit à petit
gagné la moitié du territoire français
alors quels sont les symptômes de cette
maladie bien c'est une maladie qui
provoque des céphalées forte qui
provoque une très grosse fièvre une très
grande fatigue des douleurs articulaires
parfois aussi qui peut être
asymptomatique mais c'est relativement
rare
enfin en règle générale il faut quand
même préciser que c'est une maladie qui
est plutôt bénigne
donc dès que on a des symptômes des
symptômes un peu fort de cette fameuse
grippe notamment dans la période où elle
sévit c'est à dire entre mai et novembre
alors il faut immédiatement aller voir
son médecin il faut demander à faire le
test sérologique et le médecin doit
impérativement déclaré la maladie les
autorités essayent de faire en sorte que
cette maladie ne s'installe pas sur le
territoire métropolitain et pour sa
exerce une surveillance extrêmement
importante des cas et notamment de ce
qu'on appelle les cas importés qui sont
les principaux cas que l'on trouve dans
notre pays il y en a eu à peu près un
peu plus de 300 en 2018 alors qu'est ce
qu'un cas importés c'est tout simplement
une personne qui est parti en voyage à
l'étranger qui a été piqué par un
moustique et qui va déclarer la maladie
une fois revenu sur le territoire